so I often hear Christians say that they
pray and their prayers don't work
they're not getting results it's like a
diet plan or something you know I've
been doing it I'm just I'm just not
shedding the pounds I don't know what's
wrong I have no doubt complain about
this in the past myself and the problem
is that people become discouraged from
prayer because they perceive that it's
not having the desired effect and then
they stop doing it and that's how you
end up with a body of believers in
America who don't pray we have an
unprecedented in American and it shows
uh the statistics that I've read I don't
know if they're true or not but they
sound true it's probably true I've read
that the average Christian spends
significantly significantly less than 10
minutes a day praying I've also read
that the number is actually about 1
minute a day that the average Christian
spends in prayer and that's pretty bad
especially when you consider that the
average person spends 5 hours a day
watching TV
which I don't know I mean that's mind
boggling I don't know how do you find
five hours in the day to sit on a couch
and just stare at a screen how could you
possibly carve out that much time and
how do you not get bored
but anyway five hours a day watching TV
several more hours a day staring at
computer screens and phones we're
wasting a lot of time and yet we say I
don't know I just I just can't find the
time to pray I got a guy yeah I can't
find it in my schedule I've got my
schedule right here from from about 7:00
p.m. till 1:00 a.m. I'm gonna be
watching TV can't do anything about that
I mean that's you know I've had that's
scheduled for weeks now
so I thought it would be a good thing
maybe to talk about prayer and to talk
about why our prayers may not be working
why they may not be answered from our
perspective
here are just a few points about a few
points about prayer the first thing
I think we should understand is that God
does answer every prayer said to him
but the crucial thing there is that
qualifier said to him if we pray to
somebody else that's not him then he's
not necessarily going to answer that
prayer
and if we're praying for fame and
fortune and materialistic selfish greedy
prideful things if we are praying to
satisfy our gluttony and pride and ego
and materialism that's how we're praying
then we're not praying to God we may be
attaching his name to it but we're
praying to some kind of genie that
grants wishes that's what we're pranked
we're basically praying to the genie
from Aladdin
that's who we're praying to and that's
not God
we in other words we are praying to an
idol we are idol-worshipping
the person who tells that the person who
says a selfish materialistic greedy
prayer is an idol worshiper
God responds to that prayer at all
we're probably not gonna like the
response just put it that way so just a
quick story about that and I'm
embarrassed to say that's a long time
ago when I was I don't know 20 or 21
years old I actually literally did pray
for a winning lottery ticket maybe twice
in my life I've I've purchased one of
those jackpot lotteries tickets and so I
this is this was one of those times I
think it was a I don't know it was a 300
million 400 million dollar jackpot and
so before they drew the numbers
that night I set a prayer to God
dear Lord let me win this 300 million
topics Lord please I don't ask for much
just please 300 million dollars it's all
I need okay then I'll be happy I did
pray for that and
it's it's a shameful blasphemous prayer
especially when you consider that Christ
in the gospel is is repeatedly warns us
about wealth and he says famously it's
very difficult for a rich man to get to
heaven like passing through the eye of a
needle and why is that because because
the more wealth we have the more things
we have the more attached we be we
become to those things and the less
attached we are to God
and the more that our our kind of vision
our our view of the divine of holy
sacred things the more that view is
cluttered and blocked by all of this
stuff
and that's why he tells us give up
everything
give up all this stuff and just follow
me so when I prayed for 300 million
dollars what I was really praying for
was God please make it hard for me to
get to heaven
fortunately thank God he did not
that prayer I did not win money and in
fact not only did I not win it but for
the next five years of my life I had
pretty serious financial difficulty and
I was pretty poor and I had a lot of
trouble just keeping the lights on and
putting food in the fridge and that's
how I lived in my in my
dumpy little apartment for about five
years now I'm not saying that that was
all a direct result of the prayer that I
said for 300 million dollars but I don't
think it's entirely unrelated I think
God and his wisdom may choose
so withhold blessings from greedy
selfish childish people like I was at
the time people who treat him like a
genie
he may say you know what I'm gonna
withhold now you're gonna go without for
a while
and that wit that withholding of a
blessing that thing where we we pray for
something and then God gives us the
opposite of what we prayed for which is
kind of what happened to me more than
once in my life but that itself is a
huge blessing I realized now looking
back how good it was that I was poor
during that time great because if I had
if I had money and means I would have
probably used it in selfish ways because
I was a selfish person and I would have
destroyed myself and so praise God he
did not he didn't go with my plan he
went with his
now I know that most Christians
hopefully aren't praying for hundreds of
millions of dollars you know most
Christians hopefully aren't as stupid as
I was at the time but there are many
other forms of materialistic selfish
prayers prayer that is essentially just
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
and if such prayers are answered at all
they're more likely to be answered with
rebuke and what I will say is if we do
pray selfishly and materialistically and
greedily and suddenly we look around and
we see that all of our selfish desires
are actually coming true
well then we should shudder in fear
because those blessings are not coming
from God
he is God is not going to indulge our
sinful desires God's not going to do
that if we want something sinful God is
not gonna say okay here you go
so if those blessings aren't coming from
God above then
they're coming from below and that's not
to say that everyone who's ever got
wealthy you know they that those were
bled that those were gifts from Satan
I'm not saying that I'm saying someone
who is intensely focused selfishly on
materialistic things and someone who is
greedy
when they look around and see that
things are starting to go their way
well I think it's must be much more
likely that that's Satan kind of walking
in front of them and paving paving the
path and making things very comfortable
for them so that they'll just walk very
nicely and very easily right into hell
second thing kind of related to the
first point
scripture tells us to pray unceasingly
persistently and if we're only praying
briefly in this kind of scattershot way
and only when we want something even if
what we want is not selfish or
materialistic even if it's a good thing
well then that prayer isn't gonna
necessarily work and that's because God
desires an intimate bond with us he
doesn't want to standoff at the dead at
a distance and just toss crumbs to us he
he wants to be our eternal bread he
wants us to be sustained by him through
His grace and he wants us to establish a
real connection with them a real
relationship so if we pray just every
once in a while and only when we want
something it again could be a great
blessing I think that he doesn't give us
what we want
he'll answer the prayer but you may
answer it by saying no or he may say you
want that but I'm gonna give you this
instead and we may get that answer kind
of frequently if we're not praying
habitually and unceasingly
you know if we just pray every once
awhile when we want something and
nothing more then we may get turned down
quite a bit because he's withholding the
fullness of his blessings in order to
spur us to greater hunger and a greater
desperation for his presence and that is
what God wants he wants desperation I
think God really wants us to be
desperate people he wants us to be
desperate like like a man in the desert
who hasn't had a drink of water in three
days he that's that's what he wants and
that's why in Scripture you'll notice he
never made it particularly easy for
those who came to him the people that
came to him asking for healing and
asking for miracles
he didn't often make it easy for them
they had to fight through a crowd right
like the woman who grabbed on Christ's
robe and she was shoulda said there's
throngs of people she had a fight and
just and just you know she's probably on
probably crawling and it she just grabs
at his roams
and that's what was necessary
to demonstrate her faith and that's how
she was healed or they had to tear the
roof off of a house remember the
paralytic in the Gospels and they had to
they couldn't get in Christ was inside a
house they couldn't get in through the
doors too many people so they had to
climb up on the on the roof and tear a
hole on the roof to get to Jesus or they
had to travel great distances or you
have in Matthew chapter 9 we read about
the two blind men or following Jesus and
shouting have mercy on me have mercy on
me and eventually when Jesus makes it to
the place where he was going and they
followed him all the way there then he
turns around and heals them
but they had to follow that whole time
he could have healed them at any money
he could have taken two steps and then
turned around and said yeah you're
healed
but instead he had these men who blind
he had these literally blind men follow
him over we don't know how long it was
but we can assume was a bit of a
distance and to keep following keep
shouting at mercy on me have mercy on me
and then he healed them so Jesus didn't
go door to door handing out blessings
instead he walked his path
he journeyed where he needed to go
where his mission
meant that he had to go and it was up to
the people to seek him and humble
themselves before him and ask for his
blessings in faith
you know Jesus says knock and the door
will be open and I know Christians will
cite that verse a lot and they'll say oh
just whatever you pray for you'll get
yet knock and the doors open he never
said knock once he didn't say how many
times you might have to knock you might
have to knock 10 times you might have to
knock a hundred times you might have to
you might have to knock ten thousand
times before he finally answers it he
says um he says seek and you will find
he never said that you're going to find
it the first place you look
he never said this process of seeking
will take five seconds
could take five days could take five
years could take fifty years whatever it
is
so we have to be persistent and
unceasing and keep coming back to God
keep coming back keep coming back keep
crying out to him
and and that's really what demonstrates
our faith because anyone can cry out to
God in a moment of desperation you know
in a fleeting moment of desperation or a
fleeting moment of need anyone can cry
out oh god help me save
to continue to continue following God
grasping at his robes crying out have
mercy on me to continue along that path
well that's persistence that's unceasing
prayer I think the third thing I think a
lot of us need to expand
our prayer arsenal a little bit because
there are different kinds of Prayer not
just one kind and I think this is a big
problem in Christianity today in the
West is that
people aren't really taught about prayer
we kind of assume that it's oh yeah
you'll figure it out you know you'll
pick it up on your own
it's something people need to be taught
and trained in and we need to learn that
there are different kinds of prayers
there are prayers of petitions where we
ask for something and we've discussed
that and I think for a lot of us that's
the only kind of prayer we ever say it's
just petition God give me this give me
this give me this and we may we may we
may ask for petitions we may petition on
behalf of other people which is great we
may petition on behalf of our children
our family or spouse
yet the poor the disadvantaged our
friends and those are great prayers to
say but those are also petitioned
prayers
and then you also have prayers of
Thanksgiving where we give thanks and
praise to God and I think if we're
getting shot down on our petition
prayers a lot we may have to ask
ourselves how often do we do the
Thanksgiving prayers because of its all
petition and its no Thanksgiving
except for maybe on Thanksgiving that's
the only time when we thank God that I
might be part of the problem it seems to
me it should be at least even for all
the time we spend asking God for things
we should spend time thanking him taking
him even when he says no if he says yes
to a prayer and I know I've done that so
many times where I'm praying for
something I'm praying for it and then I
get it
forget to go back to God and say thank
you for this
and I know I don't tolerate that for my
own kids
if I go out and get them some ice cream
and I hand them the ice cream they
better say thank you but how often have
I done that to our Heavenly Father or he
gives me something and I'm just like a
brat I don't even say thank you for it
but
I think even more common even if we
remember to say thank you for the yeses
how often do we forget to say thank you
for the nose
because even if God says no we should
still go back and thank
because we know that the know was what
was best for us and so it was a blessing
even still I'm so prayers of
Thanksgiving prayers of petition then we
have prayers of contrition where we ask
forgiveness for our sins that's another
one that I think Christians tend to
neglect in their one minute of daily
prayer and then there are prayers of
adoration and a prayer of adoration is a
prayer where we simply worship and
praise God
now you look at the Lord's Prayer which
Christ gave to us we see that as it has
all of these elements in it
so think about it our Father who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name
that's adoration thy kingdom come Thy
will be done on earth as it is in heaven
that's more adoration give us this day
our daily bread that's petition forgive
us our trespasses as we forgive those
who trespass against us that's
contrition lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from evil that's also
petition so this is the model prayer
Jesus says pray like this and he's not
saying that every prayer you say should
be this specific prayer these words
exactly although we should pray that
specific prayer a lot but what he's
saying is every prayer you should you
say should reflect this prayer it should
reflect some element of this prayer so
it leads with adoration praise worship
dwelling in God's holiness then it
petitions God but the petition is humble
the petition is submissive it's saying
just give me my daily bread Lord then
there's asking for forgiveness
and it's kind of a
it's it's kind of a dangerous
a request for forgiveness
were saying forgive us as we forgive
others
don't forgive others that well
and then there's the final petition
which is a petition for holiness and for
sanctification and I think when we're
asking God for things that should really
be the main thing we ask for is for our
sanctification for our holiness we
should be saying you know make me holy
Lord
fourth thing
or to focus on adoration prayers for a
moment because I think this is the kind
of prayer that is most lacking for a lot
of Christians and it was lacking for me
until recently
not every prayer that we say should
involve us saying anything not every
prayer should be said
if we really desire a connection a
relationship with him then the
conversation with God has to be a
two-way conversation and I think a
mistake that we often make is this is a
conversation we we are really bad
conversationalist okay we're like the
conversationalist in the conversation
who just dominates the conversation it
makes everything about themselves and
never listens to anybody else and it's
just horrible talking to them
I think with God it's got to be a
two-way conversation all the time we
spend talking to him explaining
ourselves and everything there also have
to be times of silence times of
listening prayers you know we should be
saying prayers where we say nothing
actually where we ask for nothing what
we simply put ourselves in his presence
we meditate upon his
Majesty and lordship and beauty and we
open ourselves up there
and then we just sit there
in his presence thinking about that's
kind of that's a that's a
contemplatively
people have different sorts of
strategies for contemplative prayer I'm
certainly no expert myself what I try to
do now try being the operative word
working on it but what I try to do is is
I try to do this every morning the
contemplative prayer and I begin by
reading a little bit of Scripture just a
short passage so as so as to put myself
in the right frame of mind and then the
next step for me is is I get on my knees
and I do think that the physical posture
is important because we are physical
beings and to be on our knees is to
physically communicate our submission to
God and the whole point of contemplative
prayer is to is to meditate upon the
presence of God so we have to think if
Christ were to appear in the flesh right
in front of us if if Christ walked into
our living room in the flesh what would
we do unless we are arrogant beyond all
comprehension we would fall to our knees
we probably fall all the way prostrate
on our faces that's what we would do
remember in Revelation John talks about
his vision of the Lord and he says when
I saw him I fell at his feet as though
dead and that is what a person ought to
do when confronted with the blinding
heavenly light of perfection so if we're
praying whenever possible I think it's
important to put our minds where our
minds need to be by putting our bodies
how our bodies need to be and I'm not
saying that every time we pray we have
to be on our knees because I know you
know some pray sometimes when I'm
driving when I'm walking when I'm doing
chores you know it's so so we could pray
in any physical position whatsoever but
we should also be carving out specific
time in the day for prayer not just when
we can fit it in when we're doing
something else which is fine as long as
we also have that time that is just for
prayer nothing else put aside all the
distractions
and in those moments I think it's so
important for us to get on our knees in
this act of submission and reverence and
this is something that I think is really
lacking not just prayer but something
really lacking among Christians in
America is reverence is this sense of
total reverence this sense of the sacred
you know that we are in front of
something truly sacred so anyway then on
my knees I asked the Holy Spirit to come
into my heart and then I spend some time
saying nothing trying not to say
anything even my in my head trying to
cancel out any thoughts of things that I
need or things I need to do and I just
imagined myself before Christ and that's
the prayer I know some people in Crowe
Templar prayer they'll they'll meditate
on the passage of scripture or they'll
meditate on the cross I think over time
you figure out what works best for you
what's the best way that God speaks to
you personally but I think this should
really be the bedrock of our prayer life
that private quiet contemplation that
passive kind of receiving of God and
receiving of it you know em speaking to
us but if we really want to hear what
he's sang to us we need to just shut up
and listen which I know we all struggle
with I certainly do but I think when we
incorporate all of these forms of prayer
and we pray unceasingly and we really
start to take our prayer life seriously
I think that's when we see that our
prayers really start to work
they really work and they work in many
ways but but here's the primary way
that I think a really
a really well grounded prayer life works
or here's here's the place if you're
really praying a lot and you're praying
well here's the place where you're
really gonna see a change you may not
see a change in anything else your
financial situation may stay the same
your your health may stay the same
everything in your life may stay exactly
the same or they may not but it may all
stay exactly the same but the one place
where you were absolutely 100%
guaranteed see a change is in your
appetites I don't mean physical
appetites I mean that
when we really have a prayer life that's
when we start to feel a deeper desire
for holy things the more we pursue God
the more of a desire we have for him and
we start to crave these we start to
crave holiness and so we feel less
desire for the hollow things it's we
want holy things not hollow things not
superficial things not not unholy things
our spiritual and intellectual appetites
grow deeper they grow more mature we may
find that a lot of the music we like to
listen to a lot of the shows we watch a
lot of the movies we watch just a lot of
the stuff we used to do no longer has
any appeal to us whatsoever and we'll
even find that certain sins and certain
temptations that we've struggled with
that have had it that have just had it
hold on us for so long
suddenly they don't have a hold on us
anymore suddenly and you might not even
notice it when it happens it's not that
you'll become a perfect person who never
sins but if there are certain sins that
have just had you in their grasp
for so long and then you really start
praying unceasingly every day constantly
that's when you find that that in it you
almost don't even notice the transition
but one day you look and that sin is
just kind of over there and you can look
at it and you can say you've got no
power on me
you've got no power
and you'll just want more of the sacred
in your life and you'll find that
certain things that you found appealing
before it aren't appealing anymore
certain things you didn't find appealing
are appealing
you'll love people more you'll hate sin
more you'll want to read the Bible more
you'll want to think about God more and
talk about him more I think when you
look at Christians who it would seem
that their appetites are exactly like
everyone else's in other words they're
you know they're just they're listening
to trashy music and they're just
watching all this trash on TV and
they're just living and consuming in
exactly the same way as people without
faith and they seemed to have no
appetite whatsoever for God prayer
church scripture well the reason why
they're like that is that they don't
pray that's that's the problem is they
don't pray and I think then the more we
change from prayer the less we look at
prayer as a thing that brings results or
a thing that works or doesn't work we
just see prayer as an opportunity to
spend time with God and to think about
him and worship Him and not always to be
asking for things but just to have our
bond with him grow stronger and stronger
and to be in his presence and to listen
to him I don't say this as someone who's
mastered the art of praying not by a
longshot but I know that this is what
prayer is and we could all certainly
benefit from praying significantly more
than we are now so maybe we should all
make that resolve make that resolution
right now all right I'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody
god speed